and i think it's very likely
it's almost obviously likely that we're
moving into the digital world
the one of the features of the digital
world
is that artificial intelligence systems
can operate
with much more power in a in a
frictionless way
in that world currently as we understand
it it's
hard to build robots that operate at
scale
and do like arbitrary large amount of
impact
damage or positive in the physical world
it's much easier to do in the digital
world do you have do you ever think
about
ai systems just swimming about
doing extraordinarily powerful
destructive things in the digital world
is that something of a concern to you or
is this something into a very distant
future
i think a lot of artificial intelligence
is
uh in the name it's simply the
replication of human intelligence
at scale automated
and pr and program programmatic meaning
that
in the analog world you could go hire a
thousand employees
or in you know an amazon case hire
millions of employees
and set a mission or a goal and push
them to go do that
that requires recruiting retention
training resources all that stuff
in the virtual world or in this digital
economy
what if you can just program the
resources and gain the same leverage
and do it at scale and do it in a very
programmatic way
and then have them actually make
decisions
in a way that doesn't require you to
have thought of every single
potential scenario or edge case that's
ultimately what we're talking about when
we talk about artificial intelligence
right
and so when you look at that when
technology's created
everyone uses it for good or bad but
both get used
right and so whether we're talking about
cell phones beepers the internet
guns whatever it's always used for good
and bad
the big question is and i think that you
know yourself and many other people have
rightfully
said this is the question really becomes
is the negative and nefarious
uses of this inadvertent potentially
or does it actually come from a
malicious person it's the intention
malicious
and to me that's what i i don't know
enough you know much more about this and
there's plenty of other people who do as
well
but i do think that there will be
nefarious actors and malicious people
but we're going to treat them the same
way we've always treated people who use
technology poorly
right we're going to understand it we're
going to identify it we're going to
control it and then we're going to end
up reversing it or preventing that from
doing that
it's the inadvertent things that i think
are actually the most dangerous
because when you have something that can
think for itself
and there is no way to leverage a
monopoly on violence
for control it's a very scary thing
and it can i mean the the thing that's
scary to me is that it can scale
arbitrarily
so it can outnumber humans very quickly
even if it's
dumber than humans and so
i don't know if we're able to reason
about a world
like let's look at the physical analog
where all of a sudden
uh let's talk about something kind of
like humans but dumber than humans like
chimps okay imagine that all of a sudden
chimps could multiply arbitrarily
quickly
and you could have like a trillion
chimps
the next day when when you when you only
had maybe a million the day before
like how does that world look different
where the [ __ ] did all these
chimps come from and they like and then
we can
we can pretend to be like well let's
hope the chimps like don't get violent
because
they don't seem to get violent when the
resources aren't constrained
but like we don't know and the problem
is it all starts by
building that first chimp multiplier
device
and everyone's like okay yeah there's a
lot of good applications you want
you know uh you can make all kinds of
arguments
for why you have more chimps maybe they
can help you out
around the house or something like that
in the physical space
but ultimately it's the unintended
consequences that you're referring to is
you don't know what's going to happen
i'm really worried about
dumb ai agents
like having impact when they're
multiplied
to a million to a billion and are
allowed to operate in the digital space
especially as we clearly are moving more
and more
of our lives into the digital space so
it's kind of terrifying because we you
know a lot of people are terrified
or like concerned about super
intelligent systems
i think i'm definitely much more
concerned about
super dumb systems at scale that that's
terrifying
i always think about um the inadvertent
but as you were talking what it made me
think of is
also the irreversible irreversible right
so it's one thing if there's uh
inadvertent
negative impact but we have
reversibility built into a system
and we can fix our mistakes yeah i think
the really scary part is when you
overlay
inadvertent mistakes with the
irreversible aspect of it
and therefore humans have no control
yeah if you if you have the trillion
chimps you can't
they're not gonna like it when you try
to start killing them off
uh all right but back to bitcoin
those chimps in the bitcoin community
anytime you bring up chimps
some people say joe rogan entered the
chat
you